Welcome back, and as before, you have
a rich playground for future reference.
Check it out, we will go through
all the code right here.
So far, it looks like a closure, and is
a function with a few extra features and
a slightly different syntax.
Not so, little grasshopper.
Functions and
closures are exactly the same thing.
They just have a different syntax.
Therefore, all the extras that closures
pack are also available to functions.
Closures and functions are just like
our alter egos for the same thing.
Like Peter Parker and Spiderman.
So the function enclosure that
I'm going to show you right now
are exactly equivalent.
They don't just do the same thing.
Check them out.
They are the same thing.
So we have first a function
that takes an integer and
returns an integer and it adds 42 to it.
And then we have a closure that
does exactly the same thing.
They look equivalent, but actually
they are more than just equivalent.
They are exactly the same thing.
Actually when the compiler finds
a function declaration such as foo
over here,
it will take the following steps.
First of all, create a closure
that takes an integer and
returns 42 + that integer.
And then assign that closure
to a constant called foo.
Sounds familiar, yeah.
That's exactly what you've done here for
bar.
So the bottom line is since functions
and closures are the same thing,
you should use whatever syntax
makes more sense at a given time.
It's up to you to choose which one
you prefer at any given point.
So if closures and functions are exactly
the same thing we should be able to
add functions to a collection,
such as an array,
as we did with the closures in
the previous playground certainly.
So let's give it a try.
I'm going to show you a few functions
and then we'll add them to an array and
iterate through the array, and call
the functions, just as we did before.
So, here we have three functions that
take an integer, and return an integer.
Just like those that we've seen before.
And we're going to add them to an array,
and see if it works.
And it certainly does work.
Here we have the three
functions with in the array.
So could we add the bar closure
over here to this array?
Think about it.
Yes.
They have the same type and
it doesn't matter
if they were defined using the closure
syntax or the functioned one.
Let's add it.
And now we can just call
all those functions and
closures that are inside stooges.
So for, and
again it works exactly as expected.
And we can display it
also as a line graph.
So now I have a question for you.
Could we add the function baz
that is here, to this array?
Think about it, or try it if you must,
but you shouldn't need it by now.